bonjour chers amis bonjour helmand au
jeu 4 et où les josy je lise ingrédients
que voilà et la jolie jeune japonaise
bien si j'apprenais je n'avais pas
l'esprit
ah oui toujours un petit peu jalouse
avait quitté l'année dernière mon des
jeux olympiques c'est toujours voilà
vous avez ça au coeur reste chère à mon
coeur
alors vous vous rappelez vous nous aviez
donné dans cette chinoise il y à pas mal
de temps alors bientôt plus de normal de
nos téléspectateurs nous en dise si
sympathique les recettes exotiques
pourquoi nous en donner vous plus et ce
japon qui fut présent pour vous il n'y a
pas tellement longtemps
valette pour nous aujourd'hui avec la
recette du ce qui est acquis pourquoi le
ce qui est acquis c'est bien parce que
c'est le plat le plus traditionnel le
plus connu le plus exporté est du japon
je pense quand on pense au japon on
pense qu'on pourra qui est une friture
ou ce qui est acquis qui est une cuisson
d'ailleurs très amusante qui ressemble
un peu à ce que nous appelons la fondue
bourguignonne
eh bien je vais essayer de le faire pour
vous aujourd'hui mais d'abord je
voudrais vous expliquer une chose qui me
paraît extrêmement important c'est que
je voudrais le franciser c'est à dire je
ne voudrais pas que l'on croit qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir tout l'outillage
japonais pendant que l' on est tous ceux
qui traditionnellement fait partie
justement de cette recette au japon pour
l'heure réalisé en france
on peut la réaliser nous le ferons
d'ailleurs dans une poêle avec des
engrais a dream en france et ce sans
faute et a deux dents fin et c'est ce
que j'ai kiffé serré de mon passé va
faire en partie je ne suis pas très
habile encore avec les baguettes il
faudra donc probablement que je me suis
un peu de mes doigts mais je pense que
nous allons parler justement de ce
matériel qui est tout de même quelque
chose de très extraordinaire
alors si vous voulez bien nous allons
commencer par le principal qui est la
casserole dans laquelle on faire ce qui
est requis
voyons cette casserole et traditionnel
on ne fait pas le sou kia qui dans autre
chose que dans cela résister c'est très
très épaisse et en fonte et on sait très
polis à force d'avoir fait de nombreux
nombreux nombreux ce qui est acquis
alors évidemment ça prend un effet de
pâtir d extraordinaire
c'est plein de charme alors évidemment
il ya aussi un petit peu de d'écriture
bien que ce soit marqué à 1 cm 23 cm 100
m ne vois pas non
alors ça c'est à la poêle pour nous oui
alors ça nous allons l'emporter par une
fois tout bêtement alors voici des
baguettes de cuisinier tout ça c'est du
matériel de cuisine y est alors ceux ci
sont des baguettes à temps pour à paris
où ils sont isolés dans le bout elles
sont en métal ceci faisait pour aller
chercher dans dans les casseroles mais
dans la friture
celle ci aussi sont des baguettes à
temps pour à mai où elles sont
métalliques également dans le boue mais
la partie évidemment en contact avec la
main et de bois pour ne pas que l'on se
brûle et puis les autres ce sont des
classiques mais de cuisinier elles sont
beaucoup plus grands voici voilà les les
baguettes avec laquelle lesquels on
mange et voici des baguettes avec
lesquels on fait la cuisine bien manger
oh oui enfin on finit par se débrouiller
en vivent à dévoyer alors voilà des
baguettes donc de cuisinier déjà
beaucoup de taille en a plusieurs
tailles voyez vous voilà deux tailles
différentes et enfin une chose qui est
très belle
ce sont les couteaux japonais alors
voyez vous voilà un couteau japonais qui
sert presque exclusivement à désosser
les cartes
alors regardez il a le tranchant d'un
seul côté et il a sa gaine de bois dans
laquelle il est toujours toujours
préservé a bien sûr bien sûr que les
couramment japonais ne le cacherai
m'enfin je le mâcherais vous verrez
alors voici le couteau le plus
traditionnel
c'est à dire celui qui est un petit peu
celui qui sert à tous et qui ressemble
étonnamment au couteau chine loin le
couteau chinois est un peu plus large de
larmes mais il ressemble particulière il
est un peu bon atout c'est à dire aussi
bien attachée qu'à découper adaptés etc
et il est il est assez curieux de penser
que effectivement il ressemble
étonnamment au couteau chinois c'est
peut-être un nom du fabricant qui l'a
annoncé le nom des propriétaires les
couteaux et c'est monsieur sug d'osaka
qui est un de mes amis alors celui-là
voyez-vous jeu là on peut laisser brûler
en l'oubliant sur l'eau
mais c'est le poteau alors de cuisinier
par excellence c'est celui avec lequel
on coupe la viande avec lequel on coupe
les légumes essai de celui dont je me
servir d'ailleurs car il ressemble celui
qui ressemble le plus possible à nos
couteaux à nous mais pas mais toujours
si toujours voyez vous il n'était guise
et que d'un côté c'est à dire que l'âme
est plate
ici d'un bout à l'autre et le tranchant
et fait part ici un plan incliné
voyez-vous et on repasse seulement de ce
côté ci 7 c'est assez curieux de penser
si haut c'est un couteau de cuisine y
est d'ailleurs il est très vieux je
crois que de père en fils il a dû faire
deux ou trois générations bien et bien
notre second qui est ce m
alors ça ou je vais vous en parlait
peut-être oui j'aurais pu vous en
parlais tout à l'heure
alors ici voyez vous on met la sauce
soja qui va servir à faire le secret à
qui mais encore une fois je ne m'en
servirai pas ici on met le bouillon
c'est à dire le consommer de volailles
ou le bouillon de volaille pas dedans
alors on mélange un peu de sauce soja et
un peu de bouillon
nous allons le faire sans avoir à nous
servir de certains alors on mange là
dedans
ce sont les bols dans lesquels on va
abattre d'ailleurs nous allons le faire
alors on bat anne f
d'abord on le bat comme ceci et puis on
vient chercher dans la casserole et on
mange à partir du bol comme ceci alors
message vous allez voir nous allons
arriver jusqu'à cette démonstration mais
tout ce matériel qui est le matériel
classique
alors nous nous en servirons pas nous
devrons faire un saut kia qui comme
n'importe qui en france dans sa cuisine
peut le faire pleurer c'est souhaitable
pour nos téléspectateurs
je le crois aussi alors je vous fais un
cadeau de 16,7 une maiko je crois que
c'est une maiko ce n'est pas une geisha
c'est une maiko je crois je ne sais pas
sur quoi que le nom de mailly fo a été
déformé autrefois c'était les enfants
chers odieux et maintenant je crois que
ce sont les apprentis d'eschau
je voulais donner je ne l'oublierai pas
alors maintenant nous allons parler des
ingrédients qui sont nécessaires à la
fabrication d'un ce qui est acquis alors
il y a des choses qui sont immuables on
ne peut pas faire de ce pays à qui ça
ambiante
boeuf et de l'entendre de la cote de
beurre coupé très très très mince à
l'envoyer vous et les couper comme du
papier à cigarettes whisky et ça c'est
très important
c'est d'autant plus important que ça va
avoir seulement quelques minutes de
cuisson samedi jambon fumé alors dit
assumer ou du jambon ne soit pas exclue
alors voyez vous on se sert d'un morceau
de gras de boeuf pour graisser le moule
à ce qui est acquis excusez moi alors on
se sert de ce morceau de boeuf pour
graisser et au lieu de graisser le moule
à sofia qui nous dresserons lapointe
alors ça c'est le premier de tous les
ingrédients nécessaires
ce morceau de graisse de boeuf qui peut
être coupé dans n'importe quel morceau
ensuite il y a les légumes comme légume
et il ya toujours de l'oignon et la
particularité de l'oignon japonais et
d'être très très doux ne presque pas
avoir vous donnions ce que l'on peut
regretter si dans certains cas mais
enfin ça a très peu coup d'oignons
ensuite il ya des champignons mais là
ils sont pas de paris ne bat là-bas ils
ne sont pas de paris s'en est champion
de tokyo ici nous utilisons des
champignons de paris leur ressemble
quand même
non non on peut tester ils ont des
champions de paris n'est ce pas il ça
existe mais en général les champignons
qui sont utilisés dans le secret acquis
100 des champignons sylvestres alors il
y à des pousses de bambou n'est pas la
pousse de bambou évidemment ça à cette
exotique
je fais tu loues disposition jeu subtil
concessions mais c'est très facile à
trouver
ensuite il y a des feuilles du
chrysanthème l'effet de claix fin des
feuilles et des fleurs des chrysanthèmes
souvent alors ça évidemment c'est exclu
mais nous aurons des épinards et
l'épinard ressemble beaucoup à la
feuille les chrysanthèmes beaucoup
beaucoup c'est très propre
alors les épinards oui oui oui c'est
très voisin ensuite yannick rousselet le
cresson alors le cresson nous avons la
notion de celui de fontaine c'est à dire
le cresson sauvage qu'emploie la paie
souvent les japonais mais nous pouvons
aussi employé dans quel sens tout à fait
tout à fait civilisé ensuite il y a le
le vermicelle alors les japonais use de
vermicelles de riz qui est un vernis
celle qui ressemble
on en trouve très facilement france
voici comment espérer mais il n'est pas
exclu que l'on utilise notre vermicelles
à nous en effet trompé rien alors il se
trouvera légèrement à l'eau avant de
s'en servir
alors on peut aussi bien trempé le
vermicelle français que le vermicelle
chinois avant il est simplement trempé
dans un peu d'eau pour le rendre souple
et aussi celui là aussi exactement de la
même façon alors non non quelques
quelques secondes alors ceci est terminé
vous pouvez nous en débarrasser alors il
reste aussi la notion de plusieurs
genres de légumes on peut également
ajouter des navets ou enfin du céleri
rave on peut également ajouter des
poireaux et alors nous allons couper
maintenant si vous voulez dans le couper
les légumes la façon la plus classique
alors cette viande également je vais
voulu leur montrer mais c'est terminé
pour moi alors je vais couper simplement
les légumes
et puis nous allons commencer le
sukiyaki l'aspect apôtres préparer les
légumes alors pelade consistant à passer
cette femme placée bien plein c'est le
plat alors allez-vous les oignons de se
couper en rondelles comme ceci envoie
celui là je ne pouvais je n'étais pas à
l'intérieur il n'est pas très joli juin
choisir notre n'était pas la dernière
non
oui je ne veux pas trop épaisses mais a
tout de même d'être au rendez-vous comme
ça si je dis ça parce que vous aller
moins vite quand vous lui faites moi
signe
le fait plus figure comparé je parlais
plus vite si je les fais très fille
parce que c'est ce que je dis c'est ça
c'est ça la vie même jour nous avons
pris si ces chemins différents
voilà l'homme est suffisamment comme
ceux ci à peu près
oui on c'est un bel oignons comme ceci
alors là je vais couper également les
poireaux alors dans le sens de la
longueur comme ceux ci dans il faut
penser que tout ça va cuire dans un laps
de temps extrêmement court puisque le
ski à qui sera fini largement à la faire
à la fin d'émission
il sort mangeable il sera parfaitement
terminé et malgré malgré le des
préparations que nous aurions pu déjà
prévoir alors voyez vous les champignons
nous allons faire exactement pareil dans
les coupes et également en gros on va
pas les émincer on va les couper en gros
morceaux comme sortie en mettre quatre
ou cinq
alors là la notion vous allez voir
d'ailleurs c'est très curieux les
champignons et janvier qui poussent sur
les arbres
c'est vrai qu'on peut joli nom apparaît
bien en fait mes enfants sont très
faciles ressent beaucoup possèdent alors
le cep est un gars de satan bien sûr qui
est un mec qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
mortelle dans la collecte pas seulement
très courte colline alors là là par
contre alors vous la notion du delà de
la pousse de bambou c'est de la coupe
est facilement alors que le reste en
nous l'avons coupée gros il fallait lire
c'est là on retrouve en la célérité
parce que l'on recommence butin par
hasard sous jean pavés c'est par cette
voie il faut très riches et donnés
pissier un client tran et je crois qu'il
ya beaucoup depuis aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont en épouse devant mots parce que de
plaisance et où certes la cuisine
cuisine non alors voyez vous c'est
incroyable ça 80 concerts ah oui oui ce
sont des boîtes on ouvre la boîte on en
extrait le on a extrait de la boîte
les pouces et on les coupe en morceaux
c'est fini bon alors maintenant nous
allons réaliser la recette alors je vais
prendre une de ces deux poils se le dit
pas assez alors ne me demandez pas les
noms japonais je ne serais pas capable d
alors je vais prendre ses baguettes
parce que ce baguette ne sont plus aussi
choisi celle là à utiliser que les
autres alors là je vivais serait oublier
cette étude
non non je n'ai pas oublié mais je
voudrais pas m'en servir c'est possible
mais on avait lutté avec les baguettes
et tout à fait relative alors la voyez
alors naturellement leur côté fondue
bourguignonne et que l'on fait cela
souvent un réchaud et que se réchauffe
et placé sur la table devant vous c'est
que tous les ingrédients 1 sont sur un
plateau et que chacun non pas chacun ne
le fait pas mais on peut hein
une des personnes et par le samu ainsi
devant tout le monde alors voyez où j'ai
mis ici ce gras et maintenant je vais
mettre ces tranches comme ceux ci dont
on ne veut pas dire que c'est un coin
puisque ces ronds sur un banc sur le
board
je vais mettre les tranches de boeuf non
tout en semblant nous temps ensemble
comme ceci cela à côté de ces tranches
de 20 devait mettre des rondelles
d'oignon je remets sur le feu schéma des
rouelles d'oignons comme ceux ci c'est
le place également à côté et puis je
m'en vais ajouter les générateurs et
messi si vous allez voir c'est très
curieux des poireaux et puis une partie
des champignons
valeo là je vais faire glisser tout ceci
façon à gagner de la place j'ai bien
senti et internationaux la nasa n'y fait
rien alors simplement je retire un petit
peu parce que rite mais la rapidité
d'exécution et toujours pour nous une
difficulté ont signé quelques passes de
suite
alors je vais ajouter une pincée de
feuilles d'épinard sens que je vais
ajouter une pincée de trois ans et puis
je vais tout de suite maintenant mettre
du bouillon et aux caisses qui sont
divisés bouillon de poule voilà et puis
de la sauce soja alors je vais mettre un
verre de sauce soja et de verre de
bouillon
lorient s'est fait alors le bouillon
c'est fait et maintenant voyez vous je
m'en vais toujours pareil à grâce à ça
va fort notre vie tous les jours ça va
cuire tout ça va fort et ça va faire de
la place et à mesure que je vais avoir
de la classe je vais ajouter davantage
d'ingrédients et pas envoyé je retourne
ici la viande qui va cuire très
gentiment les oignons que je mélange et
puis allez vous je fais venir et j'ai de
la place
et là c'est pas je vais ajouter tout de
suite une pincée de coups devant vous
par exemple que voilà alors bien une
notion très importante nous fait
remarquer pas de sel pas quoi mais pas
le sait qu'on allait venir
non on y viendra porte d'ailleurs voyez
il y en a fort cela suffit là et puis
maintenant je vais faire une place dans
le sang comme ceci pour le vermicelle
dépend de celui là qui est tout à fait
classique
nous donnerons toutes les quantités tout
net
et puis à yéo alors vous allez voir au
bout de quelques secondes je vais avoir
beaucoup de place et je vais pouvoir
continuer à ajouter petit à petit à
petit alors la notion de fondue
bourguignonne reste total à léo puisieux
nous faisons cela devant nous on mange
assuré nous mangeons tous enfin petit à
petit c'est à dire chacun choisit dans
le plat ce qu'il préfère et avec ses
baguettes il prend qui de toujours
dadian bien entendu un terrain de
l'union du vango des champignons et aux
et petit à petit à mesure que la cuisse
je voudrais pas que ça triste roddick
voilà fait ça sur quoi alors sur un
petit réchaud alors en général
maintenant c'est très moderniser
autrefois c'était toujours du charbon de
bois
mais maintenant c'est du gaz et de
l'électricité mais la plupart du temps
c'est ducasse il faut reconnaître que 80
dispositif a permis scène si ce n'était
pas celui de risques alors si absolument
aussi vite voyez vous si c'était du
vermicelle france et j'aurais mis je
l'aurais mais il aurait il leur est lui
dans les mêmes conditions
j'ai voulu maintenir à sofia alors je
vais continuer voyez vous ajoutez un peu
de champignons par exemple alors je fais
ce fait glisser ou est gentil 4 merci
voilà
et puis je peux retourner ici les blues
de bambou non ça suffira à l'époux de
vendre parce que je voudrais mettre un
peu plus beaucoup plus même ce sont 7 à
verdure alors voilà par exemple des
épinards une importante annonce et poète
libre etc pour équilibrer
c'est d'ailleurs au fur et à mesure que
nous allons prélever si nous mangions si
nous mangions de façon classique c'est à
dire si nous étions tous assis autour de
la table
et quand on leur corps comment serait
déjà mangé la viande qui est déjà cuit
alors on n'en rajouterai danse à en
ajouter d'autres et en même temps on
prendrait quelques légumes on ajoute une
autre
alors on peut rajouter comme ça pendant
très longtemps pendant oui pendant tout
le tournage à vous
fethi aussi ça arrive ça si ça arrive
aussi
enfin ceux n'étant pas là en
l'occurrence y en as roma c'est ce que
vous avez jusqu'à présent c'est pour
combien de personnes j'ai compté pour 4
personnes n'est ce pas alors là vous
vous servez toujours nous attaquer oui
je me suis toujours des baguettes je
n'ai pas dit que je m'en servais très
bien mais je rassure tout de même et
bien voilà voilà le principe essentiel
du succès acquis et il y a évidemment
cette notion de pique nique que je
voudrais souligner en effet rien ne nous
empêche un pique nique de faire une
recette de ce genre là avec n'importe
quel système de gaz propane butane ou
liquides n'est ce pas est un robinet on
met la poire là dessus on met tous dans
la poêle et ont fait un dîner ou
déjeuner complet car en fait le sia qui
représente l'essentiel de la gastronomie
japonaise d'ailleurs et on prétend que
les japonais ont importé ces coutumes du
portugal je veux bien oui mais je n'ai
jamais vu au portugal quelque chose qui
ressemble à cela sa fin on dit le
temporaire ou lacan pourra je ne sais
pas alors là oui là je crois que c'est
neutre d'ailleurs comme nous le jeu
comme sauvée de grève est allé ou alors
j'ai ajouté du piment et il peut y
arriver y en avait beaucoup
et d'où vient qu'on ne met aucun si
c'était bien parce que la sauce
elle-même comporte tous les
assaisonnements comprend d'abord elle
est très salée c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
on ajoute une partie de pouillon nom de
bouillon quand il vaut mieux me
débrouiller et puis il ya il y as au
japon des choses toutes bêtes c'est des
sources spécialisées francisé nous et
non mais ça nous ne devrons pas qu'un
existants je n'aime pas que ces cas au
japon c'est une énorme industrie mais je
ne crois pas que ça existe on a
sacrément s'éteint pas on prétend que
entre temps et à juste titre d'ailleurs
tu manges sur tout cela
alors oui je vais ajouter un tout petit
peu de bouillon
là et à partir de maintenant je crois
que nous pourrions reprendre la totalité
des ingrédients les accords passés cuit
maintenant d'action léman puis le veuf
et cuits les champignons ensemble puis
enlevé la petite pression oui je vais
l'enlever
je ne savais pas si je me souviens de
lune j'ai osé me fais prendre la plus
grande tout de m oh oui oui en assam à
faciliter un tout petit peu alors je
voudrais vous faire constater regardez
comme c'est bien cuit est la souplesse
maintenant de rien retenir qu'un il est
parfaitement cuite
alors naturellement le vermicelle
finalement et quant aux épinards alors
là il n'y a pas de questions ils sont
partis très bien que aussi voyez vous
comme ça va très très vite aussi quelque
chose qui se fait et les cas de
champignons ils sont également
parfaitement cuite alors je peux
continuer comme non il est temps d'en
manger puis dans remet à oui oui déjà au
oui oui là vous avez mis nous le
répétons si vous voulez vous nous ferons
une petite surprise après juno
alors vous voulez me faire des surprises
chez nous je suis méfiant je suis
méfiant à leur tranche alors ont pris
l'étrange de bain coupe est extrêmement
mince et dont la coque où l'entrecôte
mai mais pas dans le compte officiel
n'est ce pas il faut que ce soit du
boeuf un peu gras c'est extrêmement
important en 2002 créé 120 g de pousses
de bambou 2 gros oignons toulouse en
coupe et en rouelles 200 g de poireaux
du blanc coupé à la fois en bâtonnets
ensuite en deux pour faciliter la
cuisson est aussi aussi l'appréhension
aussi qui est importante
ils ont mis des épinards au fur à mesure
d'ailleurs remis une poignée m'enfin on
peut mettre 100 g de pignons à 150 g
d'épinards 200 g de champignons de paris
un demi litre de bouillon et
naturellement la sauce soja et va qui
était d'une importance absolument
capital va elle est en tout cas tout
dernier sur la liste alors les offrait
la notion devra intervenir tout de suite
pendant que nous allons préparer cela et
puis il ya le vermicelles de riz ou bien
alors des cheveux d'ange qui sont en
effet des vermicelles français pc
l'heure où l'autre on ne met pas les
deux et bien voilà je pense alors à 50 g
de beurre qui à servir à fear agresseurs
un verre de soja alors maintenant nous
en revenons alors nous allons d'abord
nous débarrasser de ceux ci alors il est
bien il est bien naturel que si nous
continuions si nous avions commencé à
manger nous continuer à ajouter l'oignon
les pousses de bambou et le les
champignons ne continuerions à les
ajouter dans le jeu ce qui est acquis
attendez je voudrais quand même courage
étiez vous assistiez à la dernière phase
du doubs qui a titillé l'oeuf alors dans
un bol dans votre bol de force laine un
jaune d'oeuf et en place et dans ça
c'est un affront qui 7h il osa vous avez
dans la destinant à chercher tel envoi
qui avait fait cette poésie
alors vous casser un oeuf frais comme
ceux ci dans le bol ou prenez des
baguettes
alors les baguettes l'a vu à cette vague
de cuisiniers à faire mais sérieux c'est
là et puis avec les baguettes vous vous
battez l'oeuf ceci dit c'est absolument
indispensable à 6 n'y a pas de sous qui
a acquis 100 des patients
je sais pas si on peut y arriver
peut-être tu as essayé ça ne viendrait à
l'idée de personne au japonais battre
l'oeuf avec une coque
ça va pire c'est eh bien voyez-vous à
partir de maintenant assez près alors
maintenant je vais moi peut paraît un
petit peu mort monde qui quoi si vous
voulez me faire votre surprise je suis
des vôtres dans un instant
mais par où plein bonjour bonjour le
cargo alors voici
voici un oeuf pourquoi et oui je
voudrais qu'elle nous fasse voir comment
au japon tepco
on peut manger un sukiyaki et je
voudrais aussi qu'elle me dise en toute
sincérité enfin avec un petit peu des
deux je ne sens pas le français a voulu
aller lui demander en anglais ah bon ce
sera préférable au japon bien sûr mais
aussi mou s'y adonner nom en anglais ça
vaudra mieux la liste de ce qui a été
fait là on va prendre les instruments
qui nous semblent bien délicat n'a
peut-être un peu le trac aussi malgré
tout vous avez fait ça à peu près pareil
hein ça je dois dire jusque là juste la
technique la technique se défend oui
vous n'a pas très gros appétit j'ai
l'impression que vous vous deviez y
aller avec plus de avec moins de moins
de discrétion est impressionnant et ça
nous allons chercher 2 s'est passé ne
sont pas des épinoches elle aurait passé
c'est maintenant ce ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes que dans des
créneaux sont des petites les antennes
mais ça fait rien à cela qu'il faut
qu'on vous voie à faire le geste parce
que c'est amusant
oui oui ça fait rien très bien grâce à
ces merveilleux je suis sûr que tout le
monde a pu dire vous brûler ces deux
brûlés merci merci
en plus il est bon ou va t'on je crois
que vraiment ça c'est une
alors comment fait on va faire ça dans
des petits bols comme en union
champignons oui alors tout chacun mais
pas chacun dans un petit bol alors moi
ce que j'aime surtout ridicule tout
petit peu de soirée du tout croyez que
jamais arrivé je suis sûr que non manger
avec sa maman bien celui-là
en tout cas nous dirons que mademoiselle
est plus agréable
le match est beaucoup plus délicate est
ce n'est pas moi tout ça très très bon
et je vous conseille d'en faire un jour
catherine la campagne alors voilà le
seul aubergines la petite auberge et
noyer mon visage il sert à poser les
baguettes
alors il ya toujours on peut toujours
les baguettes comme ceux ci sur un petit
objet de porcelaine ou de céramique chez
nous oui chez nous ce n'est pas tout on
est là bas c'est toujours ou un animal
ou surtout des fruits et des légumes à
nager rapporter tout ça mais c'est
parfait pour manger un petit peu pour
nous vous voulez parce que c'est
tellement envie de voir son mari et que
nous allons finir cette émission en
espérant de téléspectateurs vont avoir
envie d' énergie quand son corps
réaliser cette recette
en vous remerciant cas ce qu est en vous
contant plaint encore quelques instants
bonsoir
[Musique]